Allons-y gaiement !
-  Vous voyez ça, ça ne me plaît pas quand vous me dites :
"Allons-y gaiement", ça prouve que vous avez la trouille.
- Ne le faites pas si vous ne voulez pas Julie.
Voilà, et là, vous êtes prête pour rentrer.
- Tu peux la mettre après, peut-être ?
- Oui, on va la mettre après.
- Merci.
Voilà, vas-y, tu peux reposer.
Repose tranquillement, super.
Voilà.
Alors il y a des autogreffes, c’est-à-dire
qu’on prend de la peau chez le patient lui-même
qu’on va replacer ailleurs.
On va prendre une couche très, très mince de peau
et cette couche très, très mince, on va la poser ailleurs
et elle va prendre racine.
Alors, on la place
dans une sorte de moulinette,
on l’étire comme un bas résille
et à ce moment-là, on va avoir
une peau beaucoup plus grande
avec des tas de petits trous
comme des tas de petites plaies.
ça cicatrise en trois jours.
Tu as mal où, là ?
Au coude ?
Ça fait comment comme douleur ?
10 sur 10 ?
OK, j’arrête, j’arrête.
Est-ce que vous pouvez
m’expliquer pourquoi
on plonge un patient
dans un coma artificiel,
pourquoi on l’anesthésie,
pendant les pansements ?
On est en train de terminer
le pansement et de le fermer.
Bonjour Claire.
Bonjour Julie.
C’est une rééducation qui est douloureuse,
d’où l’importance des médicaments.
Est-ce que ça va, là ?
Oui. C’est bon.
Et du coup, combien de temps vous laissez...
Pendant 20 minutes.
Tu fais quoi comme métier ?
Mécanicien.
Il t’est arrivé quoi ?
Ça a explosé dans ma voiture,
dans le garage.
Dans la voiture ?
Tu travaillais dessus ?
Non, c’est une fuite d’essence.
Pendant deux jours, trois jours,
il y a eu une fuite d’essence dans le garage,
ensuite, j’ai mis le contact
et ça s’est allumé.
Tu as moins de douleurs qu’avant ?
Ah oui.
Là, maintenant…
tu sens que tu as récupéré ?
Oui.
Vous êtes plutôt sur la fin
de la rééducation donc ça va mieux.
C’est bon ?
Ouais.
D’accord, merci beaucoup.
- Aujourd’hui du coup,
tu es brûlée sur 20 % du corps ?
- Il y a des moments
où tu t'es remise en question
et tu as eu peur, j’imagine,
de comment tes cicatrices allaient évoluer ?
- C’est quoi le plus dur pour toi à gérer aujourd’hui ?